OK, so let's go through the solution. A news site
like New York Times, absolutely. It's an internet service, it
has lots of users and the load on the service
probably varies so the scaling of app engine could be used
a perfect match. What about a device driver testing system?
Well, it of course depends on what kind of system this
is but just the fact that device driver is part
of the title, make you think that it needs access to
low level resources within in a computer. Remember, app
engines are generic platform to build scalable applications and
from that perspective this does not sound like a
match. What about a personal portfolio site? Just because
it's a personal site and probably does not need
massive scale, does not mean that app engine can
not be of great use. App engine simplifies development
of server-side applications greatly, so this is a good match.
What about a video game? Well, if we just mean the user interface part then
app engine is not a good match, app
engine is used to develop server side applications.